I've seen Koreans comedians
come on and try to be funny
while putting black
shoe polish on their--
That's not acceptable.
Living here,
I have never felt the need
to be afraid of the police.
One thing that I really
love about Korea
and that would keep me here
is the safety.
( speaking Korean )
Oh, is this about dating?
Dating.
- It's not friend?
- No, no.
- Come on in, bruh.
- Yeah, let's go!
- Come on over.
- ( laughing )
My name is Tanaya.
- Man1ac.
- Shakerra.
- Tina.
- Sam.
( speaking Korean )
My name is Han Hyun Min,
and I am Black in Korea.
I learned so much
from you guys today.
- New community.
- New adventures
with our new friends.
( speaking Korean )
Cheers!
Narrator: South Korea
is best known for its food,
technology,
and entertainment,
including the global
phenomenon K-pop.
But when it comes
to fashion and music,
South Korea has had
a lot of influence
from African-American culture.
( music playing )
This influence dates back
to the 1950s
when the US sent forces
into South Korea
during the Korean war,
including many Black people
who decided to settle there.
Today, South Korea's
Black community is made up
of Africans
and African-Americans who
eventually decided to stay
after completing
their military service
as well as scholars
and entrepreneurs.
Within the last 30 years,
the affinity
for Black culture has grown
across South Korea's
99% ethnic Korean population,
and the influence
continues to grow
as Black people
from all over the world
have made South Korea
their home.
For this reason,
we brought together
a spectrum of Black people
living in Korea
to share their unique stories
about culture
community, and the Black
experience in Korea.
( theme music playing )
Man: Three, two, one.
I feel like my style
has maybe, like, leveled up
since I came to Korea,
'cause before
I was very much of, like,
a tomgirl, whatever.
But I know that, like--
you know, go to Walmart
with some sweatpants on.
- ( overlapping chatter )
- You know, no makeup on.
You know what I mean?
- Why you stop doing that?
- They just so comfortable.
But here in Korea,
everyone's always pretty.
They have their makeup on.
I'm like,
oh, I'm going to go to my--
- Let me put some eyelashes on.
- ( overlapping chatter )
Some cute pants on.
Let me put on the cute outfits.
I used to show cleavage
for days back in LA,
- but in Korea, it's...
- ( laughter )
...not really, unless
it's a Friday, Saturday night.
And even then
you got to cover up
on the train a little bit
so that they're not
staring at you.
So, yeah,
that's why I came over here.
I have to cover up
a little bit more
than I would in LA.
( speaking Korean )
When I travel internationally,
I'm mesmerized by people having
their own individual style.
Remember in winter
when people only wore
those long puff jackets?
Everyone owned one.
I didn't see the beauty
in those.
( speaking Korean )
But back in school,
weren't you bullied for not
wearing the long puff jacket?
Like, "Oh, you can't afford
to buy one!"
( speaking Korean )
That wasn't necessary because
at the end of the day
I could just wear
something better.
( speaking Korean )
I mean, you can!
You definitely can because
you're handsome and a model!
( speaking Korean )
If you have your own style,
people respect you for that.
But if you wear
what everyone else wears,
you're the same,
and I don't want to be the same.
I have a certain
body type here
that clothes are not
always accommodated for,
so I find myself having to
make my clothes fit
for the culture.
I'm still wearing the clothes
I would back home...
- Right.
- ...but I'm having
to make it fit
into what
is socially acceptable.
I've been living in Korea
permanently since 2019.
I like living here in Korea,
but I feel that
beauty standards in Korea
cater towards
white skin, fair hair,
and anything that revolves
around being skinny.
Sometimes
I'll go into the stalls
where they sell the clothes
on the side of the streets
and the ladies will look at me,
and they're like,
"Girl, you got too much
junk back there.
None of these clothes
are going to fit you."
And I appreciate the honesty,
but sometimes
I just want to look.
It's unfortunate,
because I feel that
there are also
Korean people who have
similar body types as me
or who have dark skin
just like me.
And I can only imagine
how they feel being
that they're Korean
and they're probably not
as accepted either.
Man: Three, two, one.
Consensus.
Listen, we're on the same line.
So, I feel like
one of the best ways
to learn a language
is to actually immerse
yourself in the culture.
And if one of those ways is
actually being with somebody,
although it's not
the main reason,
it's one of the ways
that can help.
And I feel like it's
a beneficial part on both ends
of the relationship.
Because it's always Korean,
it's also English.
I mean, for me personally,
when I first came to Korea,
and I always asked people
what's the best way
to learn the language,
they always say get yourself
a Korean girlfriend.
- Yeah.
- It's the quickest way
because you spend a lot
of time with her.
But I realized, okay,
I could also spend time
with just friends.
If you find a bunch of friends
who are really eager
to study Korean,
that can really help you a lot,
at least for my experience.
Especially foreigners
that don't speak English.
- Right, right, right.
- And then you can only
communicate in Korean.
- That's true.
- Yeah, yeah.
My name's Tanaya,
I have a tech company out here.
Been living in Korea
for five years,
( indistinct chatter )
I feel like only in Korea
could I have ever become
a tech CEO in my twenties.
I've had a very strong
dating life in Korea.
Right now, I've been seeing
someone for the past two years.
My sweetheart and I,
we actually have
a pretty good dynamic.
I think what helped a lot
with our relationship
is that he didn't really
grow up watching TV,
so he really didn't have
any preconceptions
of what someone who looks
like me should be
or what Americans should be.
He's not concerned
what other people think.
He just likes me for me.
Of course, I like him for him.
I'm curious, Hyun Min,
what do you think?
( speaking Korean )
Have you dated someone
in order to learn English?
( speaking Korean )
Oh, is this about dating?
Dating.
- It's not friend?
- No, no.
- Come on in, bruh.
- Yeah, let's go!
( laughter )
( overlapping chatter )
Man: Three, two, one.
- Whee.
- Hell, yeah!
- How you doing?
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- Who's here?
- Let's see. Okay.
I can't stand there
'cause acceptance from
the Black community.
When I'm in the states,
they call me Chinese Mike.
You know what I'm saying?
- 'Cause I-- I tell them
I'm half Asian.
- Right, right.
But you clearly sound like
a Black man, though, like--
I mean, I can sound like it,
but I can--
I mean, it doesn't mean
I'm accepted as one.
Which makes me think, am I?
You know what I'm saying?
- Oh, I see it.
- I know my bloodline,
but since I'm half-Korean
it makes me, like--
I'd be standing over there
if it wasn't for the objections
of the Black community.
Being biracial,
you guys kind of are stuck
in between this weird,
like, am I Korean?
Am I Black? Where do I fit in?
Where's my community?
But you are also biracial,
too, so...
Oh, yeah, well,
'cause I'm Black and Mexican,
but, like, all of us came out
Black, so it's like...
- ( laughing )
- I mean, like--
so it is what it is.
And it was interesting,
'cause the Mexicans
in our family
didn't want Blacks
in their family,
so I didn't really get to
partake in much of that culture.
So, yeah, that's why
I'm just black-ety Black.
I am a Black woman.
( speaking Korean )
Well, I'm half Asian,
and something a lot of people
ask me when I'm in the U.S.
is "You're not full Black,
are you?"
Or they say,
"You're biracial, huh?"
So I believe I consider myself
half and half.
50/50.
I'm 70/30.
( speaking Korean )
My mom is Korean
and my father
is from Africa-- Nigerian.
Before and during
kindergarten,
my parents took care of me...
...so I didn't consider
myself different.
But after entering school,
many kids looked at me
like I was weird,
and I was often picked on.
When I was young,
there weren't many
mixed kids like me...
...and people
had bad notions about it.
But nowadays, I think that
perception is changing.
Man: Three, two, one.
- ( muffled chatter )
- Offended is such
a strong word.
Yeah, I know. Strong, right?
- Offended is such
a strong word.
- Offended. Yeesh.
Sometimes I feel like
in some instances,
it comes from a place where
they are trying to learn.
- Right.
- But we also have to understand
appropriation can lead
to negative stereotypes
because sometimes it feels
like a cosplay of Black people.
There are also people out there
who are literally putting on
Black people as a costume.
At the end of the day,
I'm always going to
be like this.
- I can't-- so it's like...
- Mm, mm. Feel you.
- That makes sense, yeah.
- Say you like rock and--
I mean, say you like rock
and roll or something.
- But there's an image
to that genre.
- Right, I get it.
- They want to be a part
of that genre.
- Right.
- So, how can you--
I don't find that offensive.
- Right.
If that I see that, I'm like,
it makes me feel good.
I'd rather them
want to be us than--
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I get what you're saying.
At the end of the day,
when you live within
a certain culture,
you want to emulate
the good parts,
the good aspects
of that culture, right?
If you like Michael Jordan
and you wore a jersey
that said 23, I know
this guy likes Michael.
You don't have to go
above and beyond and paint
your face and try to do--
Like that?
That I'm like, nah,
that ain't it.
So it almost goes
from you appreciating it
to almost, like, mocking it.
Yeah, there's a difference
between mocking
the Black culture
and trying to make
their self look like you.
Like, when I was younger,
I've seen comedians,
like, Korean comedians,
come on and try to be funny
while putting
black shoe polish on their--
that's not acceptable.
But I don't think nobody
who put dreads in their hair,
they hated the culture.
- You know what I'm saying?
- Right.
That's how I feel.
If it's the paint thing, no.
I was going to do
this movie shoot and one
of the directors was like,
"Hey, do you know where
I can get some fake hair
to do some cornrows?"
And I was like, "For me?
I don't want cornrows
in my hair.
Are we just talking
about braids or what?"
She's like,
"No, for an actual actor."
And I was like, "Is he Black?"
And she's like,
"No, he's Korean."
So, for me, I don't
necessarily get offended.
I just want to be
the educator.
While, I'm really thankful
to be here in Korea
because I come from such
a small town in Tennessee.
So I never thought
that I would actually
be living my K-pop
choreographer dream.
Korean people normally
think that I'm very cool
when they see me,
but they also think
that I am very intimidating.
When people tell me that,
I always question, like, why?
I'm such a nice person.
I'm very bubbly.
But I can understand
because I'm different.
You know, like, they've
never really seen someone of
a difference race before.
And then also
there's the stereotypes
of Black people,
and then maybe
they're also intimidated
by my presence.
Man: Three, two, one.
( overlapping chatter )
- ( all laughing )
- Oh, I agree!
( overlapping chatter )
- Absolutely, like!
- Shut your mouth!
- Watch your mouth on TV.
- I have been unemployed
for two years, bro!
I know. Sam can tell it best.
- Go ahead, Sam, preach.
- Okay, Sam, please,
please explain to us
your situation.
Never in my wildest dreams
did I ever think
that speaking on something
that I felt like
I was entitled to speak on
would get me canceled so hard.
Like, literally, when I made
the post about blackface,
it became a topic overnight.
I couldn't do any work.
Like, they canceled me hard.
- Dropped me like a hot potato.
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah, man.
- But here's what gets me,
is that you had been
- talking about racism
before in Korea.
- Exactly, yes.
So what do you think
made this last time different?
When your platform
gets bigger, right, you have
more responsibility.
And so what you say really
affects a lot of people, right?
And I'm sure
at a certain point, they're
like, "Oh, this is Sam,
the Black guy in Korea
who's doing entertainment,"
right?
I'm always talking good
about Kor-- people like that.
But the one time
that I said something that was
perceived as negative,
they were like,
"Nah, you can't do that."
- They X'd you out.
- Exactly.
They felt like
it was an attack on them
and they X'd me out hard,
to the point where
my own Korean friends
that supported me,
- they were getting attacked.
- ( gasping )
( speaking Korean )
To be honest,
I feel like to be
a public figure in Korea
means that
you really have to watch out
for a lot of things.
I'm super careful
with my social media,
which kind of keeps me away
from using it personally.
( speaking Korean )
When you go up the ladder,
it takes place slowly,
- but going down
takes place quite fast.
- Skydive.
That is facts.
( speaking Korean )
Have a good evening! Thank you.
I work in Korea as an actor
and a TV personality.
( speaking Korean )
Are you visiting
for Thanksgiving?
I love this place so much,
everywhere I went,
I used my platform
to promote Korea.
I have experienced
a lot of good things
compared to bad things.
So, Sam, what is this called?
This is called
shrimp extraordinaire.
- Oh, okay.
- Shrimp extraordinaire. Yeah!
So, I grew up in Ghana.
Accra, to be precise.
I have five younger siblings.
And I used to cook.
I was the designated cook
of my family.
My younger siblings
are getting older now,
and it's really difficult
to connect,
and it can get pretty
lonely sometimes.
When I look back and I reflect,
two years ago, right?
I really wonder
what would've happened
if I didn't have friends
who stood, like, beside me.
- You guys were, like,
ready to go to war.
- Oh, yeah.
In August of 2020,
I experienced cancel culture.
People kept sending me a post
about a group of students
that did cosplay
but they painted
their faces black.
I went on the 'Gram
talking about
how disappointed I was.
But somehow things blew up.
and the hate that poured in
was so overwhelming
I did not know what to expect.
The truth is, it can be
too much for one person.
You guys, and there were
some of my Korean friends
who were like,
"Nah, we're going to
stick beside you."
That really meant a lot to me,
and for me that was the moment
where I realized
these guys are not
just my friends,
these guys are like family.
Man: Three, two, one.
- Uh, yeah...
- I don't know if I should
stand here or here.
So the po-po came
for y'all or...
- I'm super curious
to know what happened.
- ( imitating siren )
- Like, what happened?
- I used to party a lot.
- Right.
- And since I speak Korean,
I hear everything
that they're saying,
especially when they speak
about Black people.
'Cause that was the crowd
I used to--
you know, the military soldiers
I used to kick it with.
But, yeah, they actually said
the n-word and...
Did they realize
that you're also Black?
Or they don't know?
They didn't-- well, they knew--
yeah, we was all dark.
We were all sitting there.
Like, everybody was Black.
You know what I'm saying?
But they said it
in Korean at first
and then they said it
in English.
- Mm.
- So, I-- I mean,
then we got into
a physical altercation.
That's when it popped off.
Yeah, I hurt a couple of people.
See, that's crazy
because living here,
I have never felt the need
to be afraid of the police.
It's so safe. Every time
I see the police just strolling
around in the neighborhood,
just say hi to you.
And I'm like, yo,
you can never feel like this
anywhere else.
Like when I went
to America the first time
and I was driving,
a police stopped me.
- And I was scared!
- Of course.
Out of my-- I was like,
oh, my gosh.
I had to pretend not
to speak English.
- So I spoke Korean.
- How did you do that?
- How'd you pull that off?
- I spoke Korean
and I showed them
my Korean driver's license.
And they looked--
like, "Ah, dang."
And they just let me go.
- Nice.
- But I was scared!
I was really scared.
But I never felt that here.
And I got to say, man,
I really feel safe.
Yeah, without a doubt,
definitely living here.
Man: Three, two, one.
( all groaning )
( groans )
You know what?
I'm gonna go with agree.
- Yeah, I'm going to
stick to this one.
- Yeah, me, too.
When I first came to Korea,
there was this group
on Facebook called BSSK.
- I know what you mean!
- Brothas and Sistas
of South Korea.
That was so dramatic.
I know what you mean.
As a Black person,
you come to Korea,
- that's the first group
you need to join, right?
- Yes.
However, as an African,
I realized
that there are several
African communities here.
- Yes.
- And they stick together.
- It's separate!
- Right.
So, it's kind of like
the American--
- the Black Americans
kind of stick to themselves.
- Right, right.
I can't relate, and also
I think have a little residual,
I guess trauma from being back
in the States
where I was called things
like "Oreo"
and the other Black girls
hated me.
And then when you come
to Korea,
and I'm not even
in the same job sphere--
yeah, the community altogether
was a little lost for me.
I didn't even know there was
Black community in Korea,
and for the longest time,
I felt alone.
I expect there to be
some type of connection,
but when I actually speak
to any Black person
I feel more of a rival feeling
than I do of a community.
I'm like,
I thought we're supposed
to help each other out,
but I never found the community.
This is the strongest
community I ever found.
- Mm.
- 'Ey!
And y'all probably change
when the cameras go off.
- ( laughs ) No!
- I go by the name of Man1ac.
I was actually born
in Germany. Neuenburg.
My father was in the military.
And then we got out
to Korea in 1983.
You know,
this is the first time
we spent Chuseok together for--
after Mom passed away.
It sure is.
And, you know, actually,
I really miss that.
My father,
he's fully African-American.
My mother was Korean.
She had to raise
bicultural children,
and I know
it wasn't easy on her,
and now I have a daughter.
Lydia definitely doesn't
think that she's Black.
But on the other side,
she doesn't think
she's Korean either, so...
Man1ac: Why do you come home
crying sometimes?
You say, like,
they don't treat you right.
Every time
if I go to dance class,
they're not treating
others equally.
Man1ac: Yeah,
they don't treat you equal.
I felt that
when I was younger, too.
I remember the times
you came home crying, too,
- when you were younger.
- Don't put that. Nah.
- Nah, I did? For real?
- Yes.
- Because of a--
- What was it over?
I'm not-- I know
I got my feelings hurt a lot,
I just don't remember
everything.
There were
so many times where--
You never really
told me exactly why.
- Ah.
- But then I know that was--
I mean, I'm sure
that's what it was.
Man1ac:
Me looking different,
they'll let you know
in the playgrounds
that you're not the same color.
But I wish I didn't
speak Korean sometimes
because a lot of my problems
were when I could hear
what they were saying
and I couldn't
do nothing about it.
I try to help Lydia navigate
through all these problems
by explaining to her
that she's not the only one
that's been through it...
Okay, all right, all right.
...and the feelings that
she's feeling are natural.
And one day,
she'll get used to it,
and she'll understand that
it's just a culture difference
and it's not her.
- All right, Lydia!
- Wow.
I'm the only one
not catching anything.
Hold on.
Man: Three, two, one.
( humming )
- Oh, yay! I have friends.
- Oh!
I really thought I was
going to be the only one.
Oh. Fascinating.
( speaking Korean )
Because this is the country
I was born in.
Also because when I'm in Korea,
I feel a lot of comfort
emotionally and mentally.
I've been to a lot
of countries, and honestly,
is there a country out there
as convenient as Korea?
And the night life here
is great.
And you can run errands
late at night as during the day.
It makes me think,
"Is there somewhere
more convenient?"
I don't think so.
I feel like I'm making ways
for myself to stay here longer,
but I'm not always sure
if that's going to be
feasible or not,
- because things
are always changing.
- Changing, right.
As for me, I always joke,
I will be here until they
kick me out of the country
because-- I mean,
I know I'm always going to
be the foreigner.
So they could, you know--
( grunts )
any time they wanted to,
but me, myself, and I,
and my partner, you know,
have a pretty nice life
here in Korea.
One thing that
I really love about Korea
and that would keep me here
is the safety.
Right? 'Cause, you know,
you can leave your
cell phone on the table.
- You can leave your
computer there.
- Not around me.
- No one's going to take it.
- I could stay here
as long as I want,
but it might be because
I'm a very emotional person
and I was emotionally
damaged when I was a child
by the culture,
but I love Korea.
I mean,
I'd have to go with you.
Because of my children.
Safety, no guns--
'cause I had
a lot of friends that--
that got did in
in the States with guns,
and that's something
I just don't want to have
to worry about on the side.
You know what I'm saying?
And I feel safe sending them
to the corner store
- without anything popping
off in between, so...
- Right, right.
...I'd have to go with safety.
I don't know,
I thought the funniest part
was when Hyun Min misunderstood
the dating question.
He was like, "Oh, wait,
we're not talking about friends?
Oh, never mind.
Let me run back over here."
Knowing your experiences
makes me look at Korea
in a different kind of way.
You know, more positive,
and that you, too,
also experienced
what we experienced, so...
I'm really thankful
to be here in Korea,
but living here
for as long as I have,
I start to miss my family.
You know, you start feeling
homesick after a while.
So, yeah, I'm kind of stuck
in this weird nexus.
You guys helped me shed a light
on a different perspective.
I learned so much
from you guys today.
As a Black woman,
I feel as time progresses,
there are people
who are willing to take
chances with me,
and I appreciate them.
Were you, like, careful
with some of the answers
because of
the negative feedback you got
from being yourself in Korea?
I stopped thinking about it
and just went with my gut,
and my truth, and what
I wanted to say, yeah.
I went with the truth
and I hope it doesn't X me
out of the game.
- But, hey.
- Being an outsider
to both worlds
is very traumatizing
as a child.
But I guess I always felt
a little different,
but I made that my plus
and ran with that.
( speaking Korean )
Who is the youngest person here?
Youngest! Youngest! Youngest!
( speaking Korean )
It would be good to have
a Black community in Korea,
because the number
of Black people is quite
limited in Korea...
( cheering )
( speaking Korean )
...and it would be nice
to share our common culture
and make efforts
to tackle racism.
- ( speaking Korean )
New beginnings!
- New community.
Man1ac: New community.
New adventures
with our new friends.
( speaking Korean )
Cheers!
At the end of the day,
I am always judged
based on my color.
Like, I've been blessed
with this kind of hair.
What do you mean blessed though?
I had that in me that,
"I'm Black, I'm not beautiful,
no one will date me."
Doesn't seem like
I'm really desirable as,
like, my white friends
are more desirable.
- So you find it easy
to date an Indian.
- It's easy to date.
- Yeah, of course.
- Oh, wow. Tell me more.
- You guys touched my heart.
- Oh!
You touched my heart.